i can't believe it was only a year ago
that we watched you win an oscar for
your unforgettable performance in judas
and the black messiah
thank you
thank you
thank you
long live chairman fred
and don't forget you took home the oscar
for original song for the same film yeah
make some noise for her
thank you
i will never ever forget that night it
was amazing yeah man neither would i and
how great it is to be back at the dolby
yeah it's a tradition
as is having last year's best supporting
actor announced the winner in this
category are you ready come on man ready
over this side let's do this all right
let's go here are the nominees for
performance by an actress in a
supporting role
jesse buckley the lost daughter
ariana debose west side story
judy dench belfast
kirsten dunst the power of the dog
anjanu ellis king richard
and the oscar goes too
arianna dubose west side story
this is the first oscar and nomination
for ariana dubose
[Music]
okay oh my word um you know what what is
this
um
you know what now you see why that anita
says
i want to be in america because
even in this weary world that we live in
dreams do come true and that's really
a heartening thing right now um
if i took
the time to say thank you to every
single beautiful person who has lifted
me up on this stage you find people
would be sitting here until next oscars
so i'm not going to do that but just
allow me to say that it was the summer
of a lifetime and i am the most
privileged and grateful to have spent it
with all of you um
my god thank you steven spielberg you're
stuck with me now yay
oh
thank you christy mccoskel krieger and
tony kushner and the divine inspiration
that is rita moreno you are staring at
me right now
and i'm so
grateful your anita paved the way for
tons of anita's like me and i love you
so much
i'm gonna wrap this up and talk about
my family my mother who is here tonight
mama
i love you with my whole heart and this
is as much yours as it is mine um my
some of my tribesmen my family my love
sue jonathan diana anthony calamita um i
couldn't do what i do without each and
every one of you
so
lastly
imagine this little girl in the back
seat of a
white ford focus look into her eyes you
see
a queer openly queer woman of color and
afrolatina who found her strength in
life through art
and that's what i believe we're here to
celebrate
so
so to anybody who has ever questioned
your identity ever ever ever or find
your you find yourself living in the
great spaces i promise you this
there is indeed a place for us thank you
to the academy and thank you all
you